years ago I serve all of my jail  sentence and live prison unfortunately  and the chilling effect generated by  Beijing and Hong Kong government we  strongly aware that how they arrested  activist no matter act progress live  progressively or moderately all we ask  for is just to urge Beijing and Hong  Kong government with fraud will stop  release vitality and respond to our  course on free election even I've been  jailed for three times and I need the  face of trial on 8th of November which  means three months later but we still  keep on our fight we shall not surrender  and I urge international communities  could send a clear message to President  Xi sending troops or using emergency  ordinance is not a way out we will  continue our fight no matter how they  arrest and prosecute us